Bobby let me talk to her for a minute
because Bobby wasn't great at reading at
the table read he would often tank
sketches not on purpose but because he
was so awful it without looking at each
other we would know like telepathy well
that's a sketch I'm not going to be in
it's not gonna get picked [__] you once
pronounced opinion Buick
[Laughter]
script the word opinion this this said
Buick
so so my thing was my thing was
for a long time it was a respecting not
that I didn't respect him but I was just
like God damn it and so but prior to you
I'm listen I'm working with Deborah Mo
Michael will Alex Phil Nicole
heavyweights everybody's bringing the
Thunder comedically we know we are a
well we are the Lakers when Pat Riley
was winning Chase
but on game day wait wait every sketch I
did so we're not talking about practice
but Michael Jordan brings it Justin hard
and prac just as hard in practice all
right I'm Michael Jordan
[Laughter]
how do you think I lasted Bobby you let
me get to it okay so to answer your
question yes for three years I was aloof
towards you because I was just going
wait a minute guys it takes a
[__] time I'm going everybody
else is pulling their weight and showing
their metal yeah
so yes he's on the team but until he
shows me his medal and he can pull his
own weight yeah yeah I'm a little
skeptical okay dog now now was that the
best thing to do could I have handled
that better of course but you got to
remember how old I am I'm young I'm you
know what I'm saying I'm learning a
little wet behind the ears but I'm also
and I'm not trying to be cocky but I'm
nice with it man
I'm nice with it I've been doing it
since I was 14. yeah so let me say
something that's the first thing let me
let me do a rebuttal okay all right but
I remember at season three you were
taking a [__] on the floor in your
dressing room I was like where's the
comedy in that
there's no cameras in your dress the guy
you're sitting on your floor I know
that's just my way yeah
Samurai black people in doodoo don't mix
I get it you can look at MTV
dude's office too white people [__]
[__] don't do doodles
[Laughter]
Ridiculousness white boys
[__] don't play with dude I know I
know I know in retrospect I know all
right I don't know the n-word way okay
but but my third fight but you know I
don't know if you were there but in my
third or fourth season I started killing
it at tamarines because I didn't get
nervous anymore yes and you when I'm
nervous I can't read it but I'm not
nervous I kill it and you started
killing it on the floor yeah which
finally started making me go I I yeah
okay I accept that here's the second
thing oh
what there's more that part squash that
that one point okay that's one point all
right well just what to wrap up that
that's right I have two other things so
yeah so that's wrapped up yeah go
respect you have to earn it yeah you're
this oh you're right yeah I think in
retrospect you're right but you know you
would think that after the second year
you'd be like well he is you still had
training wheels on man
okay you know except that won't you
wouldn't you kind of
um like understand where Aries is coming
from because you feel as though younger
Comics really need to earn their [__]
these days and you feel a lot of
resentment when you see younger people
sort of just make their way to certain
things and you're like you said that I
didn't know like you feel very I didn't
know you felt that way I don't know what
you're doing I don't know what size you
are you're a Sith Lord there's the eyes
you're a [__] Mama whatever his
[__] name is man this is the Sith
Lord [__] side man your mama I tried
to defend you and say you were dyslexic
I said you were just like I'm not I'm
not like right butt picture behind Bobby
right there yeah he would be laying like
that in the dresser room on lunch breaks
yeah
wow because I'm weird
all right I don't do it anymore dude
since then I've been on network shows
all movies you've been doing your thing
and I don't act like that anymore
because I realize it's not a good thing
so we brought you at your worst yeah you
saw you know it's like a caterpillar if
you saw a [__] cat like I say though
I mean you know a deformed caterpillar
right
yeah sorry I don't know what's out there
now it's already I don't know if you can
tell if a caterpillar has you know I
mean the little downs but right anyway
if you see like a weird caterpillar
right sometimes that kind of blossoms
into something else
and not so you know I mean our word
[__] butterfly anyway let's move on
right so let's okay I got better okay
and um and you know what that first
thing yes I 100 agree with you I mean in
retrospect that's what it was and um you
know I put in dick Sushi's office I
pooed in Ike's dressing room
and notice all the people in that room
they're always watching thank you yeah
yeah I pooed in my